well professor in a previous video you
spoke about episode one of Breaking Bad
the pilot episode and we thought maybe
that would be the only episode you'd
ever watch but I understand you made a
purchase recently at a secondhand store
yes you can see I like buying books and
I go to the Charities shop nearby a
house quite regularly and last week I
found a box set a Breaking Bad
for five pounds which I thought was
quite a bargain and I thought this was a
sign that we should make another video I
took out the first one I took out the
first disc and I re-watched
episode one because I'd forgotten some
of the details and I watched episodes
two and three so today you're going to
talk about episodes two and three for us
yes
and perhaps
since it's a long time since you've seen
it perhaps I should just remind you what
it shows so in episode one the hero or
anti-hero Walter and his sidekick Jesse
were surprised by gangsters Walter
defeated two gangsters by doing some
chemistry that purportedly released
phosphorian gas ph3
and this overcame the gangsters
and episode one ends with the impression
that both gangsters have been killed by
the gas Walter and Jesse Escape by
wearing gas masks while they're driving
their camper van the main point of
episode two and three is how to get rid
of these gangsters who were apparently
dead I found the story a bit gruesome I
don't really like
unpleasant videos but I was also
irritated
because I thought the chemistry was
wrong I don't mind fantasy videos where
you assume the speed of light is very
small or something like that but when
you are presenting that you're doing
real chemistry and it's wrong
I get bit irritated
[Music]
the main problem for them is how to get
rid of one of the gangsters
who's the corpse it turns out that the
other one recovers they're real quite
unpleasant details of what they decide
to do with him I should say that I
thought the gangster who recovered bore
a striking resemblance to veritasium the
YouTuber so slightly younger version of
veritasium but fortunately nothing
unpleasant has happened to him so it was
decided by Walter
that Jesse his former pupil should
dissolve the corpse
of the Dead
um
gangster in hydrofluoric acid HF
we've done several videos with HF
and one of the problems with HF is that
it is highly corrosive
so first of all Jesse is sent off to try
and buy a container that will be
resistant to HF and correctly Walter
tells him that if she uses low-density
polythene what kind of plastic man Holly
Ethylene
well how the hell am I supposed to know
that the sort of plastic that's used for
plastic buckets it will be okay
but the problem is that Jesse can't find
a big enough container
to fit the corpse in well he doesn't try
and fit the courts but he tries to fit
himself in quite a funny scene
behind some of the stacks in the
hardware store Jesse decides to use the
bath
in his house in the bathroom
and so this is where things get a bit
strange
first of all Walter has to get the HF
and he gets the HF from the school the
high school where he's a teacher
although there is some symbolic
protection to stop people taking the
bottles some sort of wear mesh I think
it is totally unrealistic to believe
that a high school would have that many
bottles of HF
in fact it's pretty unlikely they'd have
any HF the second thing is Walter takes
two
bottles of HF which of course we don't
see the label but they look as if they
could be
two liters each or perhaps four liters
but less than a gallon altogether of HF
and this is where my problem comes in
because you will have seen from our
videos that HF can dissolve flesh but
the HF gets used up when you dissolve
flesh so imagine there's a big bath in
Jesse's bathroom and he puts in the
corpse
and the first mistake appears that he
puts in the corpse
dressed and HF will not necessarily
dissolve the clothes that the gangsters
wearing we're not told what they are and
obviously I couldn't look at the labels
of the clothes but they're quite likely
to be in some sort of artificial fiber
because not many people wear natural
fibers now
but the real thing that upsets me is
that a gallon of HF
wouldn't be nearly as enough to dissolve
a tough gangster because it gets used up
the HF isn't a catalyst it is a chemical
reagent it's reacting with the chemicals
in the gangster's body now it is
possible to dissolve bodies in acid and
there is the famous British murderer
John Hague who used to dissolve his
victims or dissolved several victims
there's arguments whether it was six or
nine but there's no argument that the
way he did it was in Drums of sulfuric
acid that contained 40 gallons so that's
40 times the amount of acid that Jesse
was using but more importantly
the people the corpses that Hague put in
the acid didn't dissolve completely and
he was finally caught because the police
discovered human remains where he had
dumped the acid of course Professor you
have you're having a problem with the
credibility of this working but of
course it didn't work
Jesse and Walt didn't dissolve the all
the body there was a whole bunch of it
left and of course it famously went
wrong when the birth dissolved through
the floor well I then then there are
several things which irritated me about
that I'm being a terrible spoils thought
but that's what you want me to do if
there isn't enough acid to dissolve the
body
there won't be enough acid to dissolve
the bath as well and the bath appears to
have been made with enameled metal
enamel is essentially a glass coating on
metal and glass dissolves quite easily
in HF
and the metal which presumably is iron
would also dissolve
but then in the story the entire ceiling
comes down in the corridor below
and what appears to be the remains of
the gangster comes through the ceiling
and one thing which I thought was a bit
disappointing is that the remains were
colored red
and if you look at our video about
trying to dissolve meat in HF
the most striking thing is that the HF
completely decolorizes the blood in the
meat so the meat goes as white as my
shirt
so there wouldn't have been red remains
coming through the ceiling after that
they were shown cleaning up the mess on
the floor of the corridor and they
seemed to do that quite sensibly
presumably using Alkali or perhaps
carbonate to neutralize the acid and
they were wearing suitable protective
clothing and gas masks though I'm not
sure how easy it is to get gas masks
that will completely protect you again
against HF fumes I thought that part was
reasonably realistic
and then they're shown posing each other
down in children's paddling pools though
it's not clear why Jesse should have had
two identical paddling pools
and why didn't they try and dissolve the
gangster in the paddling pool in the
first place it was big enough and
probably the right sort of plastic I
don't remember it was Jesse who made the
mistake it was they acknowledge it was a
mistake to put it in the bath it was
Jesse's foolishness I quite I quite
agree and
um no but what I mean is that why do
they need to go and buy and go out and
try and buy a plastic container when
they had the inflatable
um paddling pools already they also
ended up apparently by flushing some of
the evidence down the drains
and this is actually what Hague did and
there's some sort of rumor that the
remains of the boat or some remains of
the bodies were found down the drains
and there have been other Mass murderers
in the UK who've been caught by bits of
body blocking the drains on that where
they live I think the key thing and this
comes back to what you said about
um Jesse is that Walter gets really
excited
and says
so Jesse you didn't follow my
instructions
so I think the really important
take-home message to any chemists who
are watching particularly one young ones
is that the instructions are there for a
purpose and you've got to follow them
I'm sorry what were you asking me oh yes
that stupid plastic container I asked
you to buy
you see hydrofluoric acid won't eat
through plastic
it will however dissolve metal if Jesse
had listened to Walter he wouldn't have
got into the mess
even if it had enough acid
HF attacks glass
chemically it breaks the Silicon oxygen
bonds and forms silicon fluorine bonds
and the compound that dissolves away in
the liquid HF
[Music]
so
[Applause]